you know you have those moments where
your friend shows you a side of heaven
you go well this is just a game changer
for me like me tell my back to you boys
no no but it'd be like this so my buddy
normal guy cool
producer hustler but in a good way and
one day cause I got to talk to you how
to talk to you had this really awesome
idea I go what and he brings me into the
car and we're driving and he's playing
the Backstreet Boys and NSYNC and he
knows all the words by heart like you
seem like like well I'm pitch you know I
know
I'm pitch and he's going head and one
eye I know he was like tell me why and
he was breathing it like the right way
and I was like hey man tell me why I'm
seasoning to the song bro you've been
singing this a lot that you're actually
taking liberties with the saw you're
breaking you're breaking out the
boundaries here and he's and I go what
are you doing then you know me I'm like
what are you doing hold Izzy first of
all ah 30 more 33 I don't know what he
is hey buddies out there this is back in
the day you know he tells me what he
goes I'm thinking about starting a boy
band and being in a boy band I want to
be the leader of a boy back oh you're
dead serious I went out I can't be
friends with you anymore now I'll have
to throw you in a flying headlock for
good what a sure it's this thing with
these guys you see them now and they
they kind of want to break out of this
thing oh boy oh boy rather a man bands
they're still killing it are they oh
yeah well they are it was so successful
they're redoing it oh my god well you
know that's what people although make
fifty million dollars a year stone yes
all those fans you know they're older -
they still jail I'll call it the money
fight era or you can call the the era of
entertainment the entertainment error
with the UFC now it's you know there's
rankings but that's really it's really
the wild wild west where everyone wants
jumpin do this super fight and jump this
weight class and do this because they're
just looking for these big kind of
fights that are gonna sell and cross
over to pay-per-view and you know you
see Woodley going all they
seventy I'll chase gspn grew up there
it's like we got work at 70 do homie or
max obably not so much but I know he's
talking about going to 55 now he see you
know it all this started with Connor all
this - is this kind of Dana goes right
here Connor here's the keys to the arena
and he goes
cool man watch this and then here we are
yeah the thing is I don't want to
believe it did start with Connor for the
UFC this has been done for years this
was done with pride prides always made
the money fights that's why they were so
popular that's why the people wanted to
see that's why we tune in you know when
you watched Shogun who a fight
kharitonov yeah you know you knew those
fights happen not Shogun but uh ninja
yeah about small ninja what just tiny
man fighting carrot ah I was like Terra
like and just got destroyed never she
was gone in one fight yeah better I mean
so we've seen it before I think that's
why pride was so successful they put
those type of fights on you know and
then now you have these type of fights
that with with Connor
doing this type of thing but it kind of
like with pride is the wild wild west no
testing you had the legends you had the
Grand Prix's and there's the Yakuza and
all that so that that's pride and I get
that that's also how many years ago yeah
and then fast-forward to now where
they're trying to become wolf for a
minute there especially with before the
sale trying to become more mainstream
more of a major sport within the to get
into the top four of the major sports
with football baseball basketball hockey
and soccer they're trying to get in
there and so then you have the rankings
then you have established order people
are in outfits and then you give Connor
the keys and it's just like we're in
this now and and I'm if you guys know
this I'm kind of dick rad I'm a fan of
everything he's done because you beat
the game you've won you beat the game
harder million dollar says you beat the
game beat the game yes [ __ ] you money
yeah keep the game but now it's like you
look at the other divisions and where
everyone is trying to mimic what Connor
is doing and then you have just become
back and now he's out and it's just this
kind of I guess almost the leftovers
really you have the leftovers of people
going off I need that now yeah I just
can't fight Tony first and doesn't make
sense yeah but he's
he's number one I know but this guy
who's ranked seven say Nate Diaz I'd
rather fight him cuz I'm gonna get more
money well BJ Penn said this years ago
how important are the titles and should
we should even have them let's just get
in there let's put the fights on and
fight okay if there's no one wins in the
amount of time it happens no one wins
yeah but you get a flat fee to fight the
team in a fight just straight fifteen
minutes go I mean it's brilliant I mean
I don't know Marcus yeah it's hard to
market but when you talk about these
type of things I think this is perfect
for the sport the thing is is they have
to be careful it's gonna start pushing
itself towards box yeah look all you
know what this is [ __ ] what you're
saying to me right now this [ __ ]
predator or [ __ ] alpha male [ __ ]
that you and Joe Rogan and all these
guys do you I'm a survivor too okay yeah
I'm a gatherer yes I'm gonna eat the
deer me too no you're not and you have
clock you'd be waiting with my food and
I want your button here and I'll do that
too we gotta live well we all survive
differently here's how I do it yeah you
said something with that story earlier
when when if I get into a little bit of
trouble I start like if I'm really mad
I'll just I'll take the person on even
if they're as big as Steve yeah because
I might be dead I probably would be but
he'd be blind and blind
I'd take them and let's get them off I
so believe Andy yeah yes I know that
you're in trouble yeah got your eyes
though I've seen you drunk and I've seen
your energy like you have a crazy amount
of energy like where you're you're
moving at such a pace where you would be
such a handful of fire horrible yeah